البدايه من تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث عين رئيس الاوكراني
وزيرا جديدا للدفاع بدلا من اوليكس الذي
يشغل المنصب قبيلا اندلاع الحرب مع روسيا
ينحدر من القرم وهو سياسي مقرب من الرئيس
وكان له دور في المفاوضات مع روسيا بشان
صفقه الحبوب وهو عضو منتخب في البرلمان عن
حزب هولوس ونائب رئيس بعثه اوكرانيا
للبرلمان الاوروبي وجاء قراره زيلنسكي بعد
تحقيقات نجرتها السلطات القضائيه حول
شبهات فساد تتعلق بصفقه ملابس عسكريه
وشراء مواد تنوينيه للجيش ابرمتها وزاره
الدفاع
سيعرض على البرلمان هذا الاسبوع اتخاذ
قرار سياسي قررت استبدال وزير الدفاع الذي
مر باكثر من 500 وخمسين يوما من الحرب
الشامله اعتقد ان الوزاره بحاجه لا اساليب
واشكال جديده للتفاعل مع الجيش والمجتمع
سيتولى رستم اميروف مسؤوليه الوزاره يعرف
البرلمان الاوكراني هذا الشخص جيدا وننتظر
من البرلمان دعم ترشيحه